I like when they say action ok and these
are some of my favorite video clips from
the internet world where I come from
when you give birth it's to your own
father
and then you eat your father and become
him you become your father that's it it
extra Beyonce ticket
it involves one of my favorite things
and that's a dog just don't like a
person ok so as you can see there's a
dog and his glasses on pin I have an
extra Beyonce ticket if you want one and
it startled when it's told that there's
an extra Beyonce ticket and I find that
also ironic because I'm not positive
dogs are allowed in concerts so maybe
it's alarmed at how cool that is this
next step is called yes girl
Yass Yass Yass see I think the Internet
is primarily for sort of videotaping
things and then putting your voice in
them which I don't I don't love that
using your voice just get a voice
something else I just think that's
what's hackneyed give me honest and I
don't know what that means I think it
means it's been hacked into tiny pieces
alright this next video is called Jesus
Christ a little known fact
that is mother Bill Gates
I'll treat a little bit Jesus Christ
that's Jason Bourne and then they got to
this guy God Jesus Christ Jason Bourne
okay stuck up with contact cement by
Dutch town road is worth the watch and
he is perplexed by how to get this
liquid nail off of his hand
while he is trying to combine to half
four or you know your pessimist half
empty cans of liquid nail and it is just
about one of the goddamn funny scissors
yeah I mean jeez I mean jeez don't want
my camera how am I gonna turn that
camera off my best friend's Andrew W K
Andrew you pointed out correctly I think
that infidelity tops the list of morally
unacceptable issues now in this clip
Andrew W K talks with Andy levy on the
red eye fox news report and look at his
face look at its no burn on that is
weird
one percent more moral to stay married
to your wife and marry the person your
family yes these are my best videos to
offer you I ask you this watch the gore
Berger show on Comedy Central on the
comedy app you'll get watch it on the
internet on youtubes I love each of you
except for the Derek's I don't trust
Derek's